i
[Música]
la palma de cera es el árbol nacional de
colombia es una especie de mica una
especie muy amenazada y durante los
últimos años ha tenido mucha atención
por parte de los conservacionistas
dentro de los cuales me encuentro no con
mucho éxito desafortunadamente pero las
investigaciones que se han hecho sobre
la palma este año revelaron algo
interesante algunos ejemplares son
transexuales y les aseguro que no tuve
nada que ver con ello
el cambio de sexo y de género se ha
reportado regularmente en la ciencia
cada vez más sin embargo mucha gente
utiliza el argumento de la falta de
naturalidad en la comunidad del gp para
cuestionar y criticar su existencia
incluso en muchos casos eso redunda en
violencia y en discriminación hacia las
personas
lg vete
y la naturaleza en contraste encontramos
especies que parecen andar todo el
tiempo en desfile de orgullo gay'
como estas ramitas despliegan una
cantidad de colores de formas que
incluso ponen en riesgo su existencia
ante los depredadores
estas ramitas usan esa estrategia como
un mecanismo fundamental de adaptación
de innovación para la evolución nos
preguntamos entonces si existe alguna
relación entre la construcción de
identidad sexual y de género entre los
seres humanos y con la biodiversidad
cómo se construye realmente esa
identidad entre las personas y cómo se
construye en las demás especies
proveniente de la literatura la teoría
queer nos sugiere que la identidad
sexual se construye
en la interacción que tienen los
personajes que comparten una narración
todos nosotros las otras especies del
mundo compartimos ese gran esa gran
historia que es la vida gracias al adn
estamos en el mismo cuento
la teoría queer también destaca lo raro
destaca lo ambiguo destaca lo excéntrico
como cualidades que nos van a ayudar a
adaptarnos a
a los retos del cambio climático a los
retos de las nuevas tecnologías a esa
gran transformación que el mundo está
sufriendo en estos tiempos
la teoría queer además nos dice es el
cuerpo el que se va a poner en juego
cada vez más para poder asumir esa
variación tan importante que requerimos
en la adaptación
el cuerpo
se desarrolla y construye identidad
dependiendo entonces de con quién se
relaciona de cómo vive en un territorio
determinado por ejemplo los pueblos awá
en vera del pacífico colombiano viven en
unas selvas ecuatoriales tremendamente
húmedas llueve hasta ocho mil milímetros
al año con una temperatura media de 30 a
35 grados centígrados se imaginan a sí
mismos como descendientes de las lianas
de las raíces de las epífitas de las
orquídeas que crecen en los árboles
ellos construyen su identidad a partir
de su manera de relacionarse con las
plantas y con los animales desarrollan
identidades híbridas
en cambio nosotros que ya vivimos en una
civilización occidental y moderna
optamos por romper nuestros vínculos con
esa naturaleza con esos árboles con ese
bosque con esas con esos animales y
estudiar poner en la distancia esos
objetos que la constituyen cada vez que
acudimos a entender esa relación
fragmentamos el ecosistema en pedacitos
y proyectamos sobre esos pedacitos toda
la fuerza de nuestra razón
así que encandilando el objeto con lo
cual indudablemente ganamos precisión
pero perdemos en visión rompemos la
conexión que hay entre todos los seres y
construimos una visión distinta a partir
de esos pedacitos con los que
ensamblamos una colección de museo con
los que ensamblamos un catálogo por
supuesto los catálogos nos dicen mucho
de cómo es el mundo pero es un mundo que
ya no tiene identidad de género que ya
no tiene identidad sexual es un catálogo
se puede reorganizar de acuerdo a muchas
lógicas cada quien le puede dar sentido
a la manera en que se organizan puede
servir de base
para contar historias también puede
servir de base para construir un parque
zoológico para construir un jardín
botánico en fin también nos ayuda a
construir visiones de naturaleza
sin embargo normalmente esas visiones de
naturaleza acaban agrupadas acaban en
más paradas por el proceso de agregación
de todas las especies de verlo todo
junto y acabamos pensando que el mundo y
la naturaleza es una especie de brócoli
de verde genérico y fíjense ustedes cómo
a veces las políticas ambientales están
constituidas por la conservación del
verde sin realmente entender que lo que
está pasando en el mundo es un constante
arreglo y cambio de las especies que se
están relacionando y están evolucionando
activamente
realmente ese ejercicio de
simplificación del mundo de
distanciamiento del mundo ha llevado a
que construyamos una perspectiva
tremendamente homogénea del mismo una
perspectiva en la cual la diversidad y
la diversidad de género y la diversidad
sexual no son importantes
un mundo en el cual las relaciones entre
las especies y entre nosotros y la
naturaleza cambia sustancialmente de
sentido
por eso mismo creo que es tiempo de
reincorporar y rescatar la diversidad
sexual y de género en nuestras visiones
de la naturaleza es tiempo de rechazar
la homogeneidad y de darle un espacio a
la diversidad de verdad a la diversidad
que está representada por las
interacciones entre todas las personas
es tiempo de construir una versión más
gozosa más divertida y más bonita de la
naturaleza
porque no hay nada más queer de la
[Aplausos]
[Música]